.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Musik *
Es begann mit Unterleibskrebs.
Den überstand ich sehr gut.
Dann hatte ich Hautkrebs.
Den überstand ich auch gut.
2010 starb dann mein Mann.
Und 2013 hatte ich Blasenkrebs.
Ich habe keine Blase mehr.
Ich muss sagen: Wenn ich nicht
ein so starker Mensch wäre
und mich nicht so
an die Arbeit klammern würde,
wäre ich vielleicht nicht mehr hier.
Oder?
Aber das gibt es bei mir nicht.
Auch die schwere Zeit,
als mein Mann nicht mehr da war:
Ich ging arbeiten.
Arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten.
* Sanfte Musik *
So, komm, Kitty.
Geh pinkeln. Gehen wir.
So, komm.
Gutes Mädchen. Komm.
Geh pinkeln. Komm.
Hier drüben. Komm.
Gut, komm.
Maya Hauris Allzweckmittel:
die Arbeit.
Doch dann kam das Virus
und brachte den Stillstand
ihrer Chilbi-Bahnen und ihres Lebens.
In diesem Film geht es um mehr
als die Angst
vor dem finanziellen Bankrott.
Es geht um den Erhalt
des Lebenssinns.
Buongiorno. Tutto va bene?
- Si.
Auf diesen Moment haben Maya Hauri
und ihr Mitarbeiter lange gewartet.
Mit einem halben Jahr Verspätung,
jetzt im September endlich
der Start in die Chilbi-Saison.
Den gesamten Frühling und Sommer über
waren die Tütschiautos im Lager
und die Schaustellerin daheim.
Nun kehrt ihr gewohntes Leben zurück.
Jetzt wähle ich die Musik
für den Morgen aus.
Ich schaue mal,
was ich vorbereiten will.
Da habe ich mal "Ballermann-Hits".
Das hören sie noch gerne.
Dann lasse ich meist
noch die laufen.
Das ist gemischt.
Alles, was man so kennt.
Ist auch gut.
Ein schönes Mikrofon.
- Ja, das ist mein Stolz.
Das ist mein Stolz.
Früher hatte ich ein goldenes.
Dann konnte ich das hier
von einem Kollegen kaufen.
Das ist die Elvis-Zeit.
Ich liebe das Mikrofon.
Jetzt bin ich bereit.
Jetzt können sie kommen.
Die Mehrheit der Schausteller
und Schaustellerinnen
darf hier
das erste Mal in diesem Jahr
Buden und Fahrgeschäfte aufstellen.
Zwar wurde
das Zürcher Knabenschiessen -
wie die meisten Grossveranstaltungen
- coronabedingt abgesagt,
aber die Marktfahrer
haben anstelle des Megaevents
eine Light-Version, einen Mini-
Rummelplatz, auf die Beine gestellt.
Trotz Vorfreude:
Es drücken die Sorgen.
Monate ohne Spielzeit und Einnahmen
liegen hinter ihnen.
Wir sind bald bereit, mein Schatz.
Wir haben unser Erspartes
aufgebraucht.
Wir sind wirklich am Limit.
Ich kam als Schaustellerkind
zur Welt und wuchs damit auf -
wie meine Kinder auch.
Aber wir halten sie da raus.
Sie müssen nicht wissen,
was für Probleme Papi hat.
Aber mein ganzes Leben ...
... geht da drauf.
Ja.
Schwierig ist dieser Moment
auch für Maya Hauri.
Kaum lässt die Anspannung
der vergangenen Wochen nach,
fliessen die Emotionen.
Entschuldigung.
- Kein Problem.
Sie sind gerade etwas ergriffen.
Wieso?
Das haben mein Mann und ich
aus nichts aufgebaut.
Und vor zehn Jahren
ist mein Mann gestorben.
Es ist ...
... unser Geschäft.
Das ist mein Mann.
Er ist eigentlich immer hier.
Das habe ich immer in der Kasse.
Er ist ein Teil von mir.
Wahrscheinlich deswegen.
Wir hatten es nicht einfach.
Wir hatten die Chance,
dass die Quote noch rauf kann.
Und seither ist mein Mann
immer dort, wo ich bin -
auch in der Kasse.
Während der Spielsaison
ist die Schaustellerin
normalerweise mit dem Wohnwagen
in der ganzen Schweiz unterwegs.
Im Corona-Jahr aber
weilt die 63-Jährige ungewohnt oft
in ihrer Wohnung in Aarau.
* Sanfte Melodie:
"Stille Nacht, heilige Nacht" *
Es ist jetzt ja Sommer und hier
trotzdem überall Weihnachten.
Warum?
- Ich liebe Weihnachten.
Ich mag das sehr gerne,
darum lasse ich es so.
Ich bin dieser Typ:
Ich würde am liebsten
überall Kränze aufhängen.
Warum soll ich es nach Weihnachten
wegräumen?
Es kommt ja wieder.
Und in der Regel
bin ich im Sommer auch nicht hier.
Darum lasse ich alles so.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Wir schwelgen in alten Erinnerungen.
Ja ...
Das ist mein erster Tag
im Kindergarten.
Ich war extrem stolz
auf mein Täschchen.
Meine Güte,
was da alles hervorkommt!
Ich bin natürlich katholisch.
Das war meine Erstkommunion.
Da ist man immer so stolz, oder?
Oh, mein Zeugnis.
Als ich in Olten
im Café Ring serviert hatte.
Ist das das,
was Sie ursprünglich gelernt haben?
Ich habe nichts gelernt.
Meine Mutter arbeitete immer.
Eigentlich hat sich
unsere Grossmutter um uns gekümmert.
Wir gingen direkt arbeiten.
Unsere Grossmutter wohnte bei uns.
Und hat sich um alle gekümmert.
- Genau.
Sie schickte uns zur Schule, kochte
und meine Mutter konnte arbeiten.
Wo war denn Ihr Vater?
Mein Stiefvater?
- Nein, Ihr leiblicher Vater.
Den kannte ich nicht.
Nie kennengelernt?
- Nein, nein, nie.
Und auch nie versucht?
- Es ist einfach ...
Es waren die Umstände.
Du, in dieser Zeit ...
Mit sieben, acht, neun Jahren -
man denkt nicht daran.
Und als ich älter wurde,
liess ich es bleiben.
Als 22-Jährige
heiratete sie Ruedi Hauri.
Kurz darauf
kam Tochter Sandra zur Welt.
Mit einer Wurstbude fing es an.
Die Hauris bauten sich
einen Chilbi-Betrieb auf.
Seit dem Tod ihres Mannes
vor zehn Jahren
managt die Witwe
das Geschäft allein -
zu dem der Autoscooter,
zwei Kinderbahnen,
drei Karusselle
und drei Confiseriewagen gehören.
Da hat es so viel.
Ich könnte stundenlang erzählen.
Sie sagen, es gäbe viel zu erzählen:
Hatten Sie, wenn Sie zurückschauen,
ein gutes Leben?
Ja, also ...
Weil die Mutter alleine war und wir
bei der Grossmutter aufwuchsen,
bis meine Mutter
wieder heiratete ...
Ich musste als Kind viel verzichten.
Mit 14 ging ich in Wangen ...
... im Altersheim arbeiten.
Mit 14?
- Ja.
Für 50 Rp. pro Stunde.
Ich wollte unbedingt lernen,
Gitarre zu spielen.
Ich verdiente 150 Fr.
während der Sommerferien.
Und bei Willy Kuhn in Olten
kaufte ich meine erste Gitarre.
Einmal oder zweimal?
- Zweimal.
6 Fr., bitte.
- Kann man mit Karte bezahlen?
Nein, tut mir leid.
Nur Bares ist Wahres.
Sitze runterlassen und fahren!
Vorsicht bitte!
Maya Hauri in ihrem Element.
Zuversicht und Hoffnung
machen sich breit.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ist die erste Corona-Welle verebbt.
Bund und Kantone
haben die Massnahmen gelockert.
Veranstaltungen
bis zu 1'000 Personen sind -
unter Einhaltung gewisser Auflagen -
wieder erlaubt.
Die Devise: Eigenverantwortung.
Es liegt einfach eine
merkwürdige Spannung in der Luft.
Aber ich glaube,
man gewöhnt sich langsam daran.
Haben Sie selber Angst um sich?
- Nein.
Gar nicht?
Ich habe keine Angst.
Vielleicht trifft es mich,
ich kann es nicht sagen,
aber Angst und Berührungsängste
habe ich nicht.
Und ...
Ja?
Wie oft?- Was?
- Wie viele?- Eine.
Einmal.
Schichtwechsel.
Maya Hauris Schwiegersohn
löst sie an der Kasse ab.
Guten Appetit.
- Danke schön.
Dass Jung und Alt
trotz Corona den Festplatz besuchen,
bestärkt die Schaustellerin.
Auch in Zeiten wie diesen
suchen die Leute offensichtlich
Freude und Zerstreuung
auf dem Rummelplatz.
Die letzten Wochen
machte sich Maya Hauri
öffentlich für ihre Branche stark.
Im August demonstrierte sie an einer
von den schweizerischen Schaustellern
organisierten Kundgebung
auf dem Bundesplatz in Bern.
Die Forderungen:
finanzielle Unterstützung.
Trotz faktischem Berufsverbot,
sprach der Bundesrat
der Schaustellbranche
keine Corona-Hilfsgelder zu.
Jetzt, einen Monat später, dürfen die
Schausteller und Schaustellerinnen
auf kleinen Chilbis wieder spielen.
In Bern debattiert man derweil
über die Details der Finanzhilfen.
Es ist natürlich schön, wenn ich
mit dem Scooter arbeiten kann,
aber es ist natürlich
ein Tropfen auf den heissen Stein,
das muss man schon sehen,
weil wir so viel verloren haben.
Aber Sie machen heute gute Einnahmen.
Ich muss es so sagen:
Es rettet uns nicht -
keinen von uns,
die hier aufgestellt haben -,
weil wir viel zu lange Pause
bzw. ein Verbot hatten.
Mit diesem Bisschen,
das jetzt reinkommt,
kann man vielleicht
etwas Kleines ...
... wieder bezahlen.
Aber es ist schon notwendig,
dass wir etwas kriegen.
Ja, du bist eine Gute.
Eine ganz Gute, ja. Ja, ja.
Fertig.
He, du?
* Melancholische Klänge *
So, komm, Mädchen.
Wir machen ein schönes Mädchen.
Ja? Machen wir ein schönes Mädchen.
Ja.
So.
Aufstehen. So.
Hm?
Gut.
Ja, also, das ist mein Kind.
Und ja,
sie ist schon mein Ein und Alles.
Sie mag das auch,
wenn ich sie bürste ...
... und ein wenig liebkose.
Nicht wahr? Ja.
Was heisst "Kind"?
Ja, also, ich habe Grosskinder,
die ich sehr liebe.
Aber ich selber
habe keine kleinen Kinder mehr.
Sie bedeutet mir schon sehr viel.
Sie ist auch dort, wo ich bin.
Und wo ich mit Hund nicht willkommen
bin, gehe ich auch nicht hin.
Gut.
So, du warst ein gutes Mädchen.
Gut, brav.
Das war mein letzter Hund: Jimmy.
Ihn habe ich hier zu Hause.
Was heisst das?
Er ist nach Hause gekommen.
Meine anderen Hunde
sind auf dem Hundefriedhof.
Und bei ihm fand ich ...
... er müsse bei mir sein.
Also, die Asche?
- Die Asche ist hier drin, ja.
Ich fand auch, dass ich für ihn
eine schöne Urne brauche.
(Weinerlich) Dann weiss er,
dass er zu Hause ist.
Und sein letztes Halsband.
Und mein verstorbener Mann.
Das ist schön.
Und dann gibt es so Momente ...
... in denen ich weine.
Aber es gehört zum Leben.
Der Tod ist wie das Leben,
das man lebt und ja ...
* Sanfte Chilbi-Musik *
Trotz Rückschlägen:
Maya Hauri kämpft weiter.
Hier im Schachen in Aarau
hat sie in Eigenregie
einen Mini-Lunapark organisiert.
Hoi, Raul.
Guten Morgen.
Ja, jetzt machen wir die Kirche.
Nonna geht den Altar machen.
Das staubt ja.
- Oh ja.
Zusammen mit ihrem Enkel
bereitet die zweifache Grossmutter
den Altar für den bevorstehenden
Chilbi-Gottesdienst vor.
Girare.
Hoppla!
Attenzione!
Es ist immer ein Highlight,
eine Kirche im Scooter.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
da müsse alles stimmen.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Es kommt noch etwas Chichi,
wie es sich gehört.
Es soll für die Leute
ja ein Bild machen.
Die kommen von da und von da.
Die Leute kommen rein
und es muss einen Wow-Effekt haben.
Dann bin ich zufrieden.
Nein, das Pferd kommt vorne
und der Engel etwa hier.
Dann haben wir hier
noch den kleinen Engel.
Vor das Karussell.
- Genau.
Dort kann es immer
fahren, fahren, fahren.
Schaut!
Wir schauen miteinander.
Schön, oder?
Bitte?
- Mit zwei Blumen.
Super, oder?
Das habt ihr gut gemacht.
Doch schon gibt es Probleme:
Die Stäbchen für die Zuckerwatte
sind quasi alle aufgebraucht.
Hast du keine mehr?
- Fast keine mehr.
Unten in der Confiserie
hat es eine weisse Kiste.
Dort hat es.
- Dort hat es keine mehr.
Gut,
dass ihr mir das erst jetzt sagt.
Hoi, Dani, hier ist Maya.
Ruf mich bitte zurück!
Es ist wichtig. Danke. Tschüss.
Tja ...
Sie regen sich gerade etwas auf.
- Ja, das kann nicht sein.
Man hätte mir das
gestern Abend sagen sollen.
Wenn die Angestellte am Morgen kommt
und sagt,
wir hätten nur noch so viele
Zuckerwattestäbchen ...
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Bedeutet das finanziellen Verlust?
- Ja, wenn ich keine habe, sicher.
Ein paar haben wir noch,
aber das reicht bei Weitem nicht.
Die Kinder lieben Zuckerwatte.
Hoffen wir, dass er mich zurückruft.
Der Druck ist gross.
Gilt es doch,
in der noch verbleibenden Saison
rauszuholen, was zu retten ist.
Auch für Maya Hauris Tochter Sandra,
die ebenfalls Schaustellerin ist.
Zum ersten Mal
bietet sich ihr hier die Chance,
mit ihrer Bahn Geld zu verdienen.
Sämtliche Ersparnisse
seien aufgebraucht.
Wir haben einen Kredit beantragt
und der ist jetzt dann aufgebraucht.
Von was für einer Summe
sprechen wir da?
Auch nicht gerade
eine riesige Summe,
aber es hat uns doch
diese sechs Monate,
in denen wir
gar keine Einnahmen hatten,
etwas über Wasser gehalten.
Aber man weiss:
Wenn es nicht weitergeht,
ist der Kredit weg
und den
muss man ja auch mal zurückzahlen.
Von ihren Nöten
hinter den Chilbi-Kulissen
sollen die Besucherinnen und Besucher
des Gottesdienstes
nichts mitbekommen.
Dann kann ich mich
wenigstens setzen.
Ich habe den Stuhl
selbst mitgebracht.
Den Stuhl
habe ich selbst mitgebracht.
Entschuldige, es ist ...
Schön.
Es kommen immer mehr.
Und doch:
Das Thema Corona ist omnipräsent.
Maya, jetzt darf ich dich fragen:
Was hat dich getragen,
in dieser üblen Corona-Zeit, in der
wir so an unsere Grenzen kommen?
Ja, so ist es.
Als es hiess, dass alles zu sei ...
... dachte ich,
ich sei im falschen Film.
Alles abgesagt.
Dort darf man nicht hin,
da nicht ...
Da überlegte ich mir schon,
wie es weitergeht.
Ich glaube, auch viele Leute,
die jetzt hier sind,
haben auch
eine gewisse Existenzangst.
Wir versuchen mit der Chilbi light,
den Leuten
wieder etwas Freude näherzubringen.
Wenn wir daran glauben können,
dass es gut wird,
können wir alle zusammen
etwas bewirken.
Vielen Dank.
Das nehmen wir mit.
Da stosse ich auch noch an.
Auf ein Prost mit den Schausteller-
kolleginnen und -kollegen.
Als Selbstständigerwerbende
haben sie Anspruch
auf eine Erwerbsausfallentschädigung
von bis zu 5'880 Fr. pro Monat.
Das reiche aber nicht,
so ihr Argument,
um die laufenden Kosten zu decken,
die pro Betrieb schnell mal
10'000 Fr. übersteigen würden.
Immerhin: Ihre Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
zeigte Wirkung.
Der Bund sendet positive Signale
bezüglich staatlicher Unterstützung.
Das sind die Forderungen?
Wie du gesagt hast:
Auf bessere Zeiten und auf Maya!
Du hast das gut organisiert.
Ich hätte es nicht gedacht,
aber es wurde sehr gut.
- Danke vielmals.
Gibt das Hoffnung,
dass der Bund Hilfe zugesprochen hat?
Auf jeden Fall,
nur muss es relativ schnell kommen.
Prognose ist aber ja, dass es
Januar/Februar nächstes Jahr wird.
Wir haben ja schon die Reserven
vom letzten Winter aufgebraucht
und konnten keine Rückstellungen
machen.
Momentan schrauben wir alles
aufs Minimum runter.
D.h., Fahrzeuge abmelden,
Versicherungen auflösen
oder sistieren und schauen.
Das ist unser Leben.
Das ist nicht nur ein Beruf.
Es ist wirklich eine Berufung,
kann man sagen.
Das kann man nicht irgendwo lernen.
Wenn es uns mal nicht mehr gibt,
ist einfach fertig.
An diesem Nachmittag aber
läuft es noch.
Das Geschäft brummt -
auch bei der Zuckerwatte.
Hast du jetzt genug Stäbchen?
Ich habe einfach die noch.
- Im Wagen hatte es ja noch.
Eine Schachtel.
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Doch, hat mir Anna gesagt.
Eine ganze Schachtel.
Ist gut, oder? Prima. Danke.
Doch, super.
Da bin ich froh.
Als Platzchefin musste Maya Hauri
ein Corona-Schutzkonzept vorlegen.
Die Obergrenze liegt bei
1'000 Besucherinnen und Besuchern.
Es gilt: Abstand halten.
Masken sind im Aussenbereich
keine Pflicht.
Eigentlich sollte man darauf achten,
dass die Leute Abstand halten, damit
sich das Virus nicht verbreitet.
Die Angst,
dass man Ihnen vorwerfen könnte,
Sie würden
so viele Leute anziehen ...
Haben Sie das nicht?
- Im Moment nicht, nein.
Bis 1'000 Leute ist es ja offen.
Jeder, der zur Chilbi kommt,
muss auch für sich selber schauen.
Alles aufschreiben und auflisten ...
Was wir machen können, machen wir.
Wir halten das Konzept
auch strikte ein.
Aber einen gewissen Teil
muss auch die Bevölkerung,
die die Chilbi besucht, mittragen.
Auf ihrem Kontrollgang
schaut die Platzchefin Hauri
bei Tochter Sandra vorbei.
Zwar haben Mutter und Tochter das Heu
nicht immer auf der gleichen Bühne,
geschäftlich
sind sie aber miteinander verbunden.
Dass Sandra Hauri in die Fussstapfen
ihrer Eltern tritt,
war nicht geplant.
Eigentlich wollte ich nie
Schaustellerin werden.
Ich wollte
einen geregelten Lohn haben.
Ich bin da etwas heikel.
Ich hatte einfach Angst, nicht
zu wissen, was ich Ende Monat habe.
Ich bin eher etwas konservativ.
Aber als ich dann
meinen Mann kennenlernte,
war das sein Bubentraum,
mal auf der Chilbi zu arbeiten.
Dann starb mein Vater.
Dann stiegen wir
unter einer zweiten Firma ein,
um meine Mutter zu unterstützen.
Einmal.
- 3 Fr.
Maya Hauris
nächste Station auf ihrer Tour:
der Autoscooter -
und ihr neuer Lebenspartner Urs.
Ich bin voll eingeschlafen.
- Das macht doch nichts.
Ich gehe nachher auf den Einzug.
- Aha.
Wenn immer möglich, übernimmt
ihr Partner, der Buschauffeur ist,
den Transport der Fahrgeschäfte.
Und er hilft im Kassenhäuschen aus.
Bis nachher.
Vier Jetons - 10 Fr., bitte.
Danke vielmals.
So, jetzt legen wir wieder los.
Oh ja!
War es schwierig,
diesen Platz
nach dem Tod Ihres Mannes
noch einmal freizugeben?
Ja, einfach war es nicht.
Am Anfang musste ich die Trauer
und all das verarbeiten.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich
noch jemanden wie ihn finde,
der mir auch zur Seite steht.
Ich kannte ihn nicht.
Das ist vielleicht ein Vorteil.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich mich sonst überhaupt
auf so etwas eingelassen hätte.
Weil man das Gefühl hat,
man möchte auch genügen, oder was?
Ja, ich achte natürlich schon darauf
und schaue,
dass ich ihrem Tempo hinterherkomme.
Und sie legt ein zackiges Tempo vor.
Das ist so.
Und ... Ja ...
Ich bin eben schon so:
Es sollte schon stehen.
Ich denke oft: "Etwas hin und her -
das geht doch schneller."
Aber mittlerweile ...
Bei mir ist auch das Problem ...
Ich habe auch schon gesagt -
da kannst du nicht widersprechen:
"Mein Mann hätte das
schon längst hingestellt."
Ich vergesse dann,
dass er nicht aus dem Metier kommt.
Dann denke ich:
"Oh, da hast du was Dummes gemacht."
Dann gehe ich lieber weg
und sage nichts.
Ich will ja niemanden wütend machen.
Also, ich denke,
du kannst dich nicht beschweren.
Jedes Mal,
wenn ich etwas gemacht habe,
stand alles millimetergenau
am richtigen Ort.
Ja, das kommt durch meine Schulung.
Ihre Anspannung hat nachgelassen.
Der Event ist ein voller Erfolg.
Die Grande Dame der Chilbi
kassiert das Geld
bei den Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein.
Dies sind u.a. die Kosten für Strom
und die Abfallentsorgung,
für das WC-Häuschen und den Security.
Vielleicht messen wir gegen Abend
noch schnell aus.
Die Platzmiete
hat ihnen die Stadt wegen des
schlechten Geschäftsjahres erlassen.
Voilà!
Feierabend.
Jetzt schon?
Noch nicht ganz, aber ich habe
schon mal die Platzgelder.
Was ich hier jetzt machen konnte ...
... zeigt mir:
Wenn wir im kleinen Stil
weiterreisen müssen, geht das.
Und es gibt doch ein paar Franken,
bevor der Bund sagt,
was wir effektiv kriegen.
Das ist doch schon ein Lichtblick.
Dieser Lichtblick
ist bald wieder erloschen:
Drei Wochen später rollt
die zweite Corona-Welle ins Land
und macht die Hoffnung
auf weitere Geschäfte zunichte.
Von zehn Weihnachtsmärkten
bleiben Maya Hauri nur noch zwei.
Hier am Weihnachtszauber
im zürcherischen Russikon
kann Maya Hauri
wenigstens mit einem ihrer
Nostalgie-Karusselle Geld verdienen.
Dass der Bundesrat
erneut Massnahmen bezüglich
Veranstaltungen beschlossen hat,
macht ihr einen Strich
durch die Jahresrechnung.
Im Schachen
haben wir sehr gut gearbeitet.
Wir gingen auch noch weiter.
Und dann plötzlich,
wieder Knall auf Fall, war fertig.
Das ist verrückt,
dass man einfach so jonglieren kann.
Man sieht es auch an den Leuten ...
Schön sitzen bleiben! Setz dich hin!
Jawohl.
Es sah so optimistisch aus, dass man
mit dieser Zahl spielen kann.
Und dann kommt aus Bern wieder:
reduziert.
Da musst du alles nach Hause nehmen
und einstellen.
Es ist schon schlimm.
Was wurde aus dem Lichtblick?
Das ist für mich momentan
ein Nebelfeld,
da bin ich ganz ehrlich.
So, meine Lieben.
Voilà, so.
Gut.
Bedankst du dich noch?
Auf das Jahresende hin
noch ein Dämpfer:
Neu sind die Kantone
für Härtefallregelungen zuständig.
Es liegt in ihrem Ermessen,
zu entscheiden,
wer finanzielle Hilfe erhält
und ob man Anspruch
auf ein Darlehen
oder auf A-fonds-perdu-Beiträge hat.
Der Schaustellbranche
bereitet dies Kummer.
Ich habe schon manchmal
Überlebensängste.
Und ich habe ja nicht nur
eine Schiessbude, sondern noch mehr.
Aber ich
befasse mich im Hinterkopf damit,
ob ich vielleicht
noch eine Stelle annehmen muss.
Was schwebt Ihnen da vor?
Früher,
als es uns noch nicht so gut ging,
habe ich mal Schichtarbeit
an einer Tankstelle gemacht.
Ich würde auch putzen.
Ich bin mir für nichts zu schade.
Ich könnte vielleicht schauen,
dass ich ...
... einen Ort finde,
um eine Confiserie aufzustellen
und mich so über Wasser halten.
Aber am liebsten wäre mir schon,
man könnte wieder reisen
und arbeiten.
Wie der Kanton Aargau
in ihrem Fall entscheidet?
Nun heisst es warten.
Es liegt nicht mehr
in Maya Hauris Händen.
Ihr probates Allzweckmittel darf sie
in dieser Krise nicht einsetzen -
und genau das,
macht es für sie so schwierig.
Wenn du immer arbeitest
und machst und tust ...
Dann kommt auf einmal:
"Jetzt ist fertig. Schaut selbst!"
Wir können nicht mehr. Es ist zu.
Das zieht einen runter.
Wenn du dir das Arbeiten
dein ganzes Leben gewohnt warst,
ist es gar nicht so einfach,
Abstand zu gewinnen.
Ist das das Schwierige oder Schlimme
für Sie?
Ja, genau.
- Nicht unbedingt das Finanzielle.
Nein, das ist zweitrangig.
Wenn ich raus und arbeiten kann,
bin ich zufrieden.
Manchmal bin ich etwas wütend,
aber das gehört dazu.
puretype gmbh / UT-Redaktion Zug
Im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2020